el ambiente en el auditorio de uvalde
era tenso justo antes de la votación de
la junta escolar sobre el despido del
jefe de policía Pita redondo los
habitantes de esa localidad texana
expresaron su indignación por la lenta
respuesta de la policía durante una de
las peores masacres vividas en casi una
década en Estados Unidos tengo un
mensaje para Pita redondo y todos los
demás agentes de la ley que estaban ahí
ese día entreguen su placa Y renuncien a
ella no me dejéis llevarla
si fuera uno de sus hijos las cabezas
estarían rodando ahora mismo
necesitamos justicia para nuestros hijos
tras una sesión a Puerta cerrada el
consejo escolar tomó una decisión
unánime propongo que existe una buena
causa para rescindir el contrato no
certificado de Pita redondo con efecto
inmediato
Arredondo es el primer oficial en ser
despedido por la lenta respuesta de la
policía el pasado 24 de mayo cuando un
hombre armado entró a la escuela
primaria rock y mató a 19 niños y dos
profesores encar patrullar la escuela el
equipo de Arredondo y otros 400 agentes
que llegaron al lugar esperaron más de
una hora antes de actuar contra el
tirador el abogado de la redondo
presentó su defensa de 17 páginas el ex
jefe de policía dijo que se vio obligado
a desempeñar el papel de chivo
expiatorio el mes pasado la legislatura
del estado de Texas señaló un proceso
plagado de malas decisiones por parte de
las fuerzas policiales estatales y
federales se están llevando a cabo más
investigaciones